jour et nuit partout en France des
femmes et des hommes se relaient au
téléphone pour écouter ceux qui en ont
besoin ils sont le plus souvent bénévole
travail au sein de divers associations
et doivent faire face à des situations
de détresse qui souvent les screindre le
pire tel est l'univers que vient de nous
décrire ce documentaire réalisé par
Guillaume estivy un film qui donne envie
de s'interroger sur l'utilité de
l'écoute aujourd'hui dans notre société
c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant dans ce débat doc en
compagnie de nos invités Jean-Jacques
Pirès tout d'abord bienvenue à vous vous
êtes le président de SOS Amitié
Île-de-France SOS Amitié qui compte
aujourd'hui 44 associations régionales
regroupant 55 postes d'écoute et près de
1700 écoutants qui sont tous des
bénévoles cette fédération et notamment
reconnue d'utilité publique pour son
action dans la prévention du suicide on
en reparlera bien entendu dans un
instant à l'occasion de nos échanges
étudiants tiranha est également avec
nous bienvenue merci vous êtes président
de Nightline une plateforme d'écoute et
de soutien psychologique tenue par et
pour les étudiants vous pouvez peut-être
nous en dire à tout petit peu plus sur
notre line oui tout à fait c'est une
association qui a seulement 6 ans et
l'idée c'est un service d'écoute qui est
tenu par des étudiants bénévoles qui
sont formés à l'écoute active et on
ouvert la nuit à un moment où beaucoup
de choses sont fermées et du coup à ce
moment-là n'importe quelle étudiant peut
soit nous appeler soit nous contacter
par chat par écrit et se livrer vite et
son sac raconter tout ce qu'il a envie
et quelqu'un sera là pour l'écouter et
c'est tout ce qu'on a vu finalement dans
ce documentaire et on va y revenir bien
sûr dans un instant avec Jacques
digneton également bienvenue à vous vous
êtes
psychanalyste on vous a vu c'est à toute
fin du documentaire absolument et pour
cause vous accompagner les écoutants
auprès de SOS suicide on aura aussi
l'occasion évidemment d'en reparler dans
cette émission merci de votre présence à
tous 3 pour ce pour ce débat doc
Jean-Jacques Pirey je la première
question c'est de savoir combien est-ce
qu'il y a de sites d'écoute en France
combien de personnes sont des écoutants
bénévoles en France et tous ces chiffres
on les trouve nulle part on a essayé de
les trouver dans le cadre de la
préparation de cette émission pourtant
il y a une pléthore de site des coups de
comment est-ce qu'on explique qu'on est
aussi peu donner sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de
réponse scientifique à vous donner ou
statistiques en l'occurrence je crois
que ça peut s'expliquer peut-être par le
fait qu'il y a quelques quelques
associations de ligne d'écoute
généraliste comme la nôtre même si vous
l'avez rappelé la prévention du suicide
et pour nous un objectif important mais
donne exclusif et ce prix des stades du
mal-être mais disons que nous sommes à
guichet assez large pour accueillir un
grand nombre de souffrance en revanche
il y a beaucoup d'associations qui sont
nés alors je regarde Florian parce que
c'est c'est le cas sur des éléments de
finalement de segmentation de notre
société alors les ét ça peut être les
femmes battues les enfants etc et
finalement la liste de ces cas
particuliers auxquels les lignes
d'écoute ce sont dédiées est extrêmement
importante alors je suis un fichu par de
mémoire mais de vous donner vraiment le
un nombre qui pourrait correspondre à ce
qui à ce qui existe en France mais je
crois que l'explication c'est vraiment
dans ce phénomène de aller au plus près
de ce que sont certaines catégories en
1960 c'est peut-être une des plus
anciennes de ces fédérations
néanmoins si on comprend bien ce que
vous venez nous dire la tendance est
claire il y a de plus en plus de
services d'écoute sur un marché on va
dire les choses comme ça de plus en plus
segmenter c'est ce que vous venez de
nous dire comment est-ce qu'on peut
l'interpréter ça alors cette
segmentation répond aussi à une
segmentation dans notre société comme le
disait tout à l'heure Jean-Jacques
pierrez il se trouve que
vraisemblablement on va vers une société
de plus en plus individualiste
et une société individualiste a besoin
quelque part de reconnaissance et cette
reconnaissance on la trouve dans des
dans des groupes voir des sous-groupes
et à partir de là il est un petit peu
normal que ce que vous appelez un marché
soit de plus en plus segmenté parce que
c'est une offre qui répond à une demande
tout simplement demande des
professionnels par exemple vous évoquiez
des services dédiés aux soignants et
Dieu sait si dans le contexte sanitaire
que nous connaissons maintenant depuis
presque deux ans c'est important les
professionnels sont aussi demandeurs de
services d'écoute c'est assez surprenant
ça ne s'adresse plus uniquement aux
particuliers comme c'était le cas de SOS
Amitié notamment du côté des étudiants
vous êtes un acteur
important du service d'écoute j'imagine
qu'il y a d'autres services d'écoute
pourquoi Nightline se distingue des
autres en la matière par exemple on est
le premier service d'écoute étudiant en
France en terme historique et en termes
de
2016 2016 et en fait les nightlines
existent dans le monde anglo-saxon
depuis une cinquantaine d'années et en
France on n'avait jamais existé et du
coup nous on l'a lancé à Paris et
maintenant on est présent dans 5 villes
en France et on essaye de s'aimer
partout sur le territoire de manière à
ce que tous les étudiants puissent y
avoir accès et l'intérêt du coup nous
notre créneau là où on se positionne
c'est c'est de dire en tant qu'étudiant
on a peut-être envie de pouvoir parler à
un de ses pairs à quelqu'un qui a aussi
vécu la période du confinement la
période découvre-feu et ça c'est quelque
chose de très particulier quand on est
étudiant et le fait de pouvoir le
partager avec quelqu'un qui a un peu la
même culture qui parle un peu la même
langue ça crée immédiatement une
proximité dans l'appel qui est très
précieuse et qui facilite le fait de
s'ouvrir et de parler de son intimité
comment est-ce qu'on l'explique ce
retard à comparer avec d'autres pays
notamment les États-Unis alors surtout
avec le Royaume-Uni qui ont été les
pionniers des nightlines
moi j'ai le sentiment que en France le
une énorme stigmatisation encore de la
santé mentale c'est un sujet dont on
parle très peu qui est revenu un peu
dans le débat public avec le confinement
et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
un gros problème et en particulier chez
les étudiants c'est très très manifeste
il y a 30 à 40 % des étudiants qui vont
traverser un moment de mal-être
psychologique c'est extrêmement
inquiétant dans la mesure où il y a très
peu de solutions qui leur sont offertes
certains sont bien accompagnés
heureusement on leur proche mais ceux
qui ne l'ont pas qu'est-ce qu'ils font
et des services des coupes comme
Nightline permettent de donner accès
finalement à
un soutien extérieur à tout le monde on
va regarder un premier extrait du
documentaire il s'agit de Marie qui est
une écoutante et qui nous livre un des
secrets central de l'écoute on en parle
juste après il s'agit du silence
une des choses qu'on nous apprend
beaucoup à utiliser ça va être le
silence
le silence qui est très important pour
permettre à l'appelant
de parler à son propre rythme
sans jugement
sans conseil il appelle pas pour qu'on
lui dise ce qu'il a à faire
l'appelant il appelle pour parler parce
que on sait qu'aujourd'hui
parler et probablement le moyen le plus
efficace pour lutter contre le passage à
l'acte il y a beaucoup de choses dans ce
qui dit là par Marie alors ça peut
paraître paradoxal mais la clé pour un
bon écoutant si on a bien compris ce qui
nous est dit dans ce documentaire et
dans ce témoignage de Marie c'est le
silence oui
évidemment et le silence c'est ce qui
permet d'abord de donner les vraiment
l'hospitalité et une place centrale à la
personne qui nous appelle si on commence
par débiter un discours évidemment on
remplit pas notre rôle donc le silence
c'est important pour les personnes qui
effectivement comme cette évidence
portage dans documentaire pardon a
besoin de sortir des choses
et là aussi des difficultés parfois à le
faire et notre silence ne doit pas pour
autant être interrompu par l'envie
d'extirper quelque chose à la personne
le silence est une n'est pas vide ce
n'est pas du vide il faut lui laisser sa
chance pour que le moment les paroles
sortent et que les changes puissent
commencer le silence est aussi important
pour nous parce qu'il nous permet aussi
de nous écouter en quelque sorte pendant
les appels peut-être mais c'est
important d'être c'est une double écoute
en fait l'écoute c'est l'écoute de la
personne qui nous appelle mais aussi on
doit être à l'écoute de soi-même pour
être assez vigilant par rapport à
d'éventuelles dérapages il y a aussi une
règle d'or c'est vous venez de le dire
c'est à dire qu'il ne faut surtout pas
avoir de projets porter un jugement sur
ce que dit l'aplomb il faut il faut
écouter sans grille de lecture sans GPS
en quelque sorte et écoutez c'est aller
vers une zone de non connaissance on
écoute vraiment quand on ne sait plus
lorsqu'on a plus de boussole vous avez
été formé de votre le côté à écouter les
autres cette règle d'or du silence par
exemple élémentaire dans votre
position oui je rejoins complètement ce
qui a été dit d'ailleurs j'ai une petite
anecdote sur un appel que j'avais pris
il y a quelques années et sans rentrer
dans le détail c'est une personne qui
parlait de d'un film qu'il avait vu et
en fait il y avait cette histoire autour
de comment ça s'était passé comment il
avait vécu et ensuite ce moment de blanc
où j'aurais pu décider de rebondir sur
quelque chose et finalement de d'aller
dans une direction que j'avais choisi et
en gardant un silence en fait la plan du
coup arrondi lui-même et a fait le lien
avec ses propres expériences et là on
est parti sur quelque chose d'intime de
profond et peut-être la chose qui qui
attendait de sortir finalement de cette
discussion et le silence l'a permis et
je pense que c'est c'est un enseignement
à garder pour sa vie quotidienne quand
on parle à des personnes et ben
finalement laisser un petit temps de
blanc ça permet peut-être à l'autre de
reconfigurer ses pensées et de d'arriver
à trouver les bons mots parce qu'il se
passe plein de choses dans la tête de la
plane pendant que nous on entend juste
le silence il est magnifique dans ce
alimentaire c'est c'est précisément qui
s'appelle je vous écoute c'est à dire il
y a l'écoute il y a le jeu il y a le
vous et bien entendu la formation dans
nos associations va porter sur un mode
d'écoute je dirais pas un style mais une
façon d'écouter qui va être différente
suivant qu'on a affaire en effet à des
associations généralistes à des
associations plus spécialisées et cette
écoute va déterminer ce qu'est le jeu
l'écoutant et ce qu'est le vous l'aplomb
et dans une moindre mesure pour le vous
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
très structurant je crois que le la
remarque qui a été faite par Marie dans
le documentaire qui est une remarque
large parce que elle aborde plusieurs
sujets n'est-ce pas mais en particulier
pour revenir sur celui du silence il est
vrai que c'est pas si courant dans la
dans notre vie de tous les jours dans
notre vraie vie qu'il y ait des silences
et le fait de laisser des silences ça ça
permet à un implant de se concentrer sur
peut-être quelque chose qui qui n'aurait
pas envisagé de dire qu'il va découvrir
lui-même au moment où il va reprendre la
parole et cette respiration cette
respiration que constitue le silence on
la retrouve dans le documentaire de
Guillaume etivy qui a qui a souhaité
comment dire ponctuer en quelque sorte
son documentaire d'un certain nombre de
de moments poétiques qui n'ont rien à
voir directement avec l'écoute mais qui
qui sont effectivement qui font sentir
au spectateur ce qu'est une respiration
je dirais vous écoutez les écoutant oui
oui comme je leur dis de ne pas donner
de conseils une mais difficile de le
randonner mais ce que ce que je
considère c'est en effet que
l'écoute c'est pas c'est pas tellement
le savoir-faire avec des recettes avec
des
non c'est plutôt un savoir-être c'est ce
que j'essaie de transmettre c'est ce que
j'essaie de développer comme une éthique
dans cette association néanmoins il y a
un point central sur lequel on
s'interroge et qui pas beaucoup
développé finalement dans le
documentaire que nous avons vu c'est la
formation des écoutants on a affaire par
exemple SOS amitiés sont 1700 bénévoles
sont pas des professionnels il faut les
former ces personnes comment est-ce
qu'on les forme et on les forme à quoi
très exactement alors les formes
justement à avoir cette cette posture
d'écoute qui en même temps même s'il y a
des éléments de psychologie on va dire
les choses très simplement comme ça qui
font partie du programme de formation de
les amène pas à se croire des
substitudes des psychologues ou des
psychiatres des psychothérapeutes que
très souvent les gens qui nous appellent
ont car à peu près si j'ai cette amitié
je sais pas si c'est la même chose c'est
l'écoute mais il y a presque 50% des
gens qui nous appellent qui relèvent
d'une prise en charge psy voilà donc il
faut former c'est un exercice difficile
lorsque l'on a des gens profondément
déprimés lorsqu'on a des bipolaires
lorsqu'on a des schizophrènes qui
appellent évidemment tout ça ça demande
chez les écoutants une ressource en
matière de savoir faire peut-être pas
mais en tout cas comportemental adapté
la situation de base il y a des éléments
évidemment alors on vient plus tout à
fait par hasard il y a une appétence
pour un certain nombre de sujets de ce
type mais j'ai de la formation échelle
ce métier la formation s'étale sur en
moyenne d'information initiale sans
parler de la permanente c'est 4 à 5 mois
il y a des psychologues prestataires
extérieurs voilà on a un séminaire de
sur trois jours et d'aller dans le temps
alors là c'est les apports plutôt à
caractère théorique et puis il y a une
formation dite pratique qui se fait avec
des écoutantes et des écoutants
référents qui en général un peu de
bouteilles si vous passez l'expression
qui ont à peu près tout entendu en gros
et qui accueille à l'occasion de sans
doute les stagiaires car on est
stagiaires quand on arrive avec ce
amitié quel que soit son âge et il y a
comme ça une douzaine 12 à 14 double
écoute puisqu'on il nous écoutent écouté
voilà pendant lesquels ça leur permet à
la fois de voir quel type d'appel nous
recevons donc de profil de la plante
mais aussi comment nous nous comportons
à l'écoute voilà c'est service d'écoute
par les étudiants pour les étudiants qui
se présente chez vous et comment vous
sélectionnez vos écoutants chez natline
il suffit d'être étudiant donc on a des
nos écoutants ils ont entre 18 et 25 ans
étudiant en médecine il y a des
étudiants en médecine mais on a des
étudiants en tout il y a des étudiants
ensemble des étudiants dans des
formations techniques enfin c'est très
diversifié et finalement il y a pas
tellement une sur-représentation des
étudiants psychologie ou des étudiants
en médecine et c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi de donner les clés de
l'écoute à des personnes dans plein
plein de milieux différents et qui vont
exercer aussi après différents métiers
et finalement le message est aussi que
tout le monde peut demande à écouter et
nous on aimerait bien que cette
formation à l'écoute on puisse la
développer de plus en plus et auprès de
tout le monde finalement si toute la
communauté étudiante aussi bien les
enseignants que le personnel
administratif que les étudiants savaient
écouter même dans la vraie vie et ben
finalement ça changerait beaucoup de
choses sur la manière d'aborder les
problèmes en tout cas nous on fait ça
avec nos bénévoles est-ce qu'il y a des
écoutants étudiants bénévoles chez vous
qui jettent les ponts parce que c'est
trop dur on a une attention très
particulière au bien-être de nos
bénévoles à la manière dont ils prennent
les appels et pour que ça les affecte
pas dans leur dans leur propre vie à eux
et ça arrive de temps en temps que
certains appels puissent faire écho avec
des situations personnelles et dans ce
cas là nos bénévoles se mettent en
retrait de la ligne d'écoute ils peuvent
être suivis par les psychologues avec
lesquels on travaille de manière à
prendre le temps et ensuite décider soit
de revenir soit d'arrêter l'écoute alors
je vous posez cette question parce qu'on
va voir un deuxième extrait du film qui
concerne l'impact de l'écoute chercher
les écoutant justement parfois ça
m'arrive de terminer les coûts mais j'ai
mal partout parce que j'ai eu quelqu'un
qui avait une telle énergie de désespoir
qui a fallu
c'est la noyée qui a fallu repêcher et
réanimer que je suis j'ai l'impression
qu'on m'a tabassé quoi autrement dit
c'était épuisant d'être écoutant en tout
cas ça peut l'être ça peut l'être ça
peut être
ce sujet
c'est une vraie c'est aussi c'est
pourquoi je pense que le mieux est de de
ne pas s'identifier ni à une situation
ni à une personne comme là où à
l'évidence c'était tout à fait tragique
mais je pense que dans une certaine
mesure les les écoutants sont largement
formés à ne pas effectivement
s'identifier comme je leur dis parfois
en m'amusant un petit peu quand il y en
a un qui pleure c'est pas la peine de
pleurer ça en fait deux qui pleurent ça
n'avance à rien mais c'est un peu ça pas
trop d'identification pas trop de
projection non plus ce que disait Marie
tout à l'heure pas de projet ça va très
loin le pas de projet on pourra
peut-être en parler tout à l'heure
cette oui vous voulez
être aussi à l'écoute de soi-même de ce
qui se passe et on voit très bien qu'il
y a certains appels qui sont pas neutres
par rapport à notre bien-être puisqu'il
était question de bien-être tout à
l'heure on commence à avoir des
dépositions difficiles à tenir on a
besoin de bouger etc tout ça ce sont
évidemment des signaux que nous envoyons
nous-mêmes sur le fait que quelque chose
se passe dans la paix qui nous mène à
l'aise donc il faut toujours écouter ça
nous on n'est pas effectivement des des
éponges il y a une une bonne distance je
préfère dire une bonne proximité mais
qui suppose
que les gens qui nous appellent et tous
les signaux physiques que nous pouvons
ressentir sont des éléments indicateurs
de d'un malaise que nous commençons à
ressentir soit par un excès de
d'implication dans l'appel soit pour
d'autres raisons qui tiennent à des
échos à notre propre vie et les épisodes
douloureux qu'on a pu traverser et
quelquefois révélateur même absolument
l'écoutant ne soupçonnait pas comme
comme sensibilité particulière alors
SOS Amitié je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
est reconnu d'utilité publique pour son
action dans la prévention du suicide et
vous avez bien précisé que c'était non
exclusif bien entendu les services
d'écoute des SOS Amitié néanmoins c'est
le fameux passage à l'acte dont parlait
Marie tout à l'heure c'est une situation
de détresse absolue ou l'écoutant peut
craindre un passage à l'acte là on est
dans la situation extrême à laquelle
sont souvent confrontés les écoutants de
SOS Amitié alors heureusement pas si
souvent que ça autrement dit le passage
à l'acte imminent ou qui a déjà eu lieu
sous forme de prise de substances et
évidemment est assez rare mais
l'évocation d'un projet suicidaire est
évidemment alors là c'est son cœur
d'écoute évidemment mais mais nous aussi
évidemment donc ce sont toujours des
appels extrêmement difficiles parce que
donner à quelqu'un alors il y a des cas
de figure extrêmement différents
quelqu'un de jeune qui a 25 ans ça m'est
arrivé et qui qui était en train de
passer à l'acte qui a été repêché en
rompant d'ailleurs l'anonymat qui est
presque contractuel dans la relation
avec les gens qui qui nous appellent ça
a été une épreuve très difficile c'était
la nuit j'en suis ressorti très touché
alors jusqu'au bout est-ce que votre
service d'écoute peut se mettre en lien
avec un service médical un service
d'urgence pour les alerter sur ce sur
cet appel non il y a un élément
important dans ces anonymat c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas tracer de nous-mêmes
les appels donc si on tente de sauver
une vie heureusement nous faisons et
nous réussissons
très largement c'est la négociation il
faut pouvoir négocier avec la personne
qui nous fait part de son appel l'appel
c'est pas forcément un appel au secours
il faut se méfier tout ça ça peut être
un au revoir à la société via une
institution que nous sommes à ce
moment-là pour la présenter cette
société donc c'est une négociation je
parlais de la personne de 25 ans il
fallait absolument la sauver
après on peut respecter aussi la volonté
de se suicider donc c'est il y a un
problème éthique à la clé de cette
question là une personne qui a atteinte
d'une maladie incurable qui souffre
horriblement qui a 85 ans on peut pas
lui dire ce que ils vont un petit peu la
vie est belle alors vous conseillez
suicide écoute là on touche le cœur du
problème posé aux écoutants à partir on
appelle celui-ci des coûts
c'est qu'on entend passer à l'acte alors
justement non non et heureusement parce
que sinon ça serait été extrêmement
épouvant pour nos écoutants bien sûr
donc je crois que
ce que disait Jean-Jacques pires tout à
l'heure par rapport au différents
suicides il y a l'appel suicidaire qui
est un appel effectivement alors
un amoureux une amoureuse un voisin un
parent je ne sais qui et en général la
plante n'en fait pas mystère et on sent
bien ce qu'il est en train de se tramer
ça peut être par rapport à l'écoutant
qui représente cette société c'est à
dire ce que je viens de nommer
mais ça c'est un appel qui généralement
aboutirait plutôt à ce qu'on appelle
exactement ok heureusement et puis et
puis il y a d'autres formes de suicide
tout à l'heure je crois que c'est Marie
qui parlait de passage à l'acte le
passage à l'acte c'est quelque chose de
d'extrêmement violent dans la mesure où
c'est une une rupture avec toute parole
et Marie opposait la parole et le
passage à l'acte et elle avait bien
raison car en cas de passage à l'acte
la marge de manœuvre est extrêmement
tenue et bien entendu que là il faut
essayer avec la parole alors même que le
passage à l'acte est précisément cette
rupture de la avec la parole avec le
chenille ferme donc forcément
le rôle de l'écoutant devient deviennent
majeur et et extrêmement éprouvant bien
sûr et selon les chiffres dont on
dispose il y aurait entre on va dire
entre 9000 et 12000 suicides en France
par an et c'est un taux l'un des tous
les plus importants aujourd'hui en
Europe vous avez été confrontés à ce
type de problème du côté les des
étudiants qui appellent Netline
la question du suicide n'est pas posée
on est sur d'autres sujets chez les
étudiants ou ce sujet est là aussi posé
et peut-être de manière de plus en plus
effective avec la crise que nous
connaissons la crise sanitaire que nous
connaissons oui la question du suicide
est bien présente malheureusement chez
les étudiants c'est environ 10 à 15% de
nos appels qui évoquent le suicide de ce
qui est à peu près comparable à la
plupart des lignes d'écoute il me semble
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que derrière
les idées suicidaires il y a souvent une
multitude de problèmes une multitude de
difficultés
très souvent de l'isolement dans les
appels qu'on reçoit
et tout ça a été malheureusement très
renforcé pendant la crise sanitaire et
c'est très net sur l'isolement qui est
assez matriciel dans les appels qu'on
reçoit qui qui a tendance à catalyser un
peu toutes les formes de détresse
il se renforce et l'isolement social à
force à force de finalement d'être loin
de tout le monde et d'être on se
retrouve avec soi-même ça ça peut
engendrer une détresse très forte au
point que nos appellants parlent de
suicide on parlait tout à l'heure de
cette question du suivi évidemment de
ces personnes et vous dites tout cela
doit rester anonyme j'imagine que c'est
votre c'est le cas aussi de natline
c'est à dire aucun suivi des appelants
il y a peut-être des personnes qui vous
appellent qui vous ont appelé à
plusieurs reprises on n'ouvre pas un
dossier pour par écoutant on a aucune
suivi des aplomb pardon c'est aussi une
différence importante avec une thérapie
chez un psychologue par exemple et on a
on a la même politique d'anonymat et
donc de confidentialité donc chaque
appel qui commence est un nouvel appel
même si la personne a déjà appelé on
recommence à zéro et on pourra on a
évidemment pas accès au numéro on n'a
pas accès à l'adresse IP quand il s'agit
d'un chat et la personne peut nous dire
ce qu'elle veut et on est là pour
écouter et c'est aussi ça qui est
intéressant finalement il y a aucune
limitation aucune barrière aucune gêne à
avoir puisque tout est confidentiel
c'est anonyme on peut vraiment se livrer
et finalement peut-être plus qu'avec ses
propres proches avec qui on a peur
d'être jugé on a peur des conséquences
dans un service d'écoute comme les
nôtres et ben tout ça tout ça est
possible et c'est ça qui fait la
singularité aussi de ce soutien on
observe même que certains appellants
sont capables de de parler de choses
tout à fait intimes qui n'ont même pas
évoqué auprès de leur psychothérapeute
ou de leur analyste alors même qu'ils
sont depuis plusieurs années en
psychothérapie
c'est quand même intéressant ça nous le
disent d'ailleurs ce que je vous confie
je ne peux pas en parler à mon
psychiatre ou à mon psychothérapeute ou
en psychanaliste lorsqu'il est là donc
on voit bien que c'est un animal et
cette mise à distance puisque nous
sommes pas en présentiel nous écoute
évidemment au téléphone ou via le chat
c'est un animal est absolument
fondamental pour libérer vraiment la
parole y compris sur des choses qui
seraient à dire à des thérapeutes mais
qui ne passent pas voilà qui ne passe
pas la bouche qui ne sortent pas en
revanche cette anonymat peut-être et
vous est-il imposé par la loi c'est une
question que je vous pose ou c'est un
choix délibéré des choix
s'il ne permet pas de suivi on a souvent
pour l'essentiel des implants qui qui
sont des appelants réguliers on les
appelle même des habitués parfois
c'est-à-dire des gens qui ont besoin il
y a une première fois bien sûr mais
cette première fois se multiplient au
fur et à mesure que la personne est
toujours dans la crise qui a fait
qu'elle appelait une première fois et
après ça peut être même dans les moments
envie ou tout va à peu près bien
l'habitude est prise autrement dit on
fait partie de la famille en quelque
sorte mais une famille un peu curieuse
puisque on ne sait jamais rencontré
qu'on ne connaît pas les noms des uns et
des autres mais disons que c'est une
présence potentielle et ce métier qui
rassure au moment où il y a un coup de
mou donc on appelle il y a des gens qui
nous appellent toutes les semaines assez
régulièrement les gens qui appellent
tous les jours et puis des gens qui nous
appellent de temps en temps donc on a on
a donc un foyer de fidèle en quelque
sorte avec ce métier on parler de la
crise tout à l'heure la crise a amené
des primo à plans ce qu'on appelait des
primo à plomb mais qui deviennent
maintenant des apnées pour nous c'est
une augmentation de peu près 30 à 40%
des appels on recevait à peu près 6 à
7000 appels par jour on est maintenant
sur 8 à 10 000 en moyenne 10000 étant
généralement sur le compte de la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons depuis
maintenant c'est un élément extrêmement
intéressant parce que les les personnes
donc qui se sont mises à nous appeler
pour la première fois ne reste sûrement
pas appelé est-ce que ces métiers en
dehors de la crise sanitaire leur vie
probablement allait relativement bien un
peu comme comme tout le monde et là le
premier confinement en particulier a été
un élément déclenchant et là on a vu le
processus s'engager comme il avait été
pour d'autres personnes auparavant ce
qui fait que on pensait qu'avec
l'amélioration alors c'est difficile de
parler de ça aujourd'hui du climat
sanitaire parce que mais bon on pensait
que les gens allaient essayer de ne plus
nous appeler non ils sont restés là
Florian tira vous pouvez un petit peu
quantifier les choses ou aussi du côté
des étudiants c'est vrai que cette crise
elle a mis en lumière les invisibles une
manière générale mais la précarité
étudiante presque en particulier dans
dans le lot des personnes qui ont été
frappées plein fouet par cette crise
sanitaire alors c'est difficile
d'évaluer exactement l'impact de la
crise sanitaire puisque contrairement à
nos collègues de SOS Amitié et de
suicider coûte Nightline a seulement 5
ans et du coup notre
ce qu'on appelle augmente énormément
d'années en année on fait plus que
doublé chaque année et donc ça a encore
été le cas l'année 2021 et l'année 2020
également et c'est notamment lié pour
les étudiants spécifiquement au fait que
il y a eu la détresse et la précarité a
été beaucoup exposé sur les réseaux
sociaux avec des comptes Twitter des
comptes Instagram qui évoquaient le fait
que les étudiants n'allaient pas bien on
a vu ces images d'étudiants qui
faisaient la queue pour se nourrir et le
fait de parler de ça et nous aussi on a
pris notre part là dedans en
communiquant sur la santé mentale en
disant n'hésitez pas à appeler il n'y a
pas de petits problèmes vous pouvez en
parler on est là pour vous écouter et
finalement ça ça crée quand même une
dynamique sur le fait que oui on a tous
une santé physique mais on a aussi une
santé mentale on doit aussi en prendre
soin et pour en prendre soin les lignes
d'écoute peuvent être une solution et
c'est notamment à cause grâce à cette
dynamique que nos lignes d'écoute ont
été plus sollicités donc
il faut évidemment s'attrister du fait
que la détresse psychologique soit forte
et augmente chez les étudiants mais on
peut quand même se réjouir du fait que
les quelques solutions qui existent
comme comme la nôtre soit utilisée et
permettre d'aider pas mal de gens la
détresse psychologique elle a augmenté
quasiment partout dans toutes les
professions dans toutes les tranches
d'âge à cause de cette fameuse crise
sanitaire est-ce que ça veut dire que
les lignes les services d'écoute dont on
parle aujourd'hui le rôle des écoutants
a lui aussi pris une ampleur tout autre
que celle d'avant crise sanitaire oui
sans doute ça a été sensible au moment
du premier confinement à cause de
l'isolement que cela engendré mais sinon
pour moi aussi les choses ont beaucoup
changé au niveau de mon écoute des
écoutant parce que justement à cause du
confinement beaucoup de choses se sont
passées en visio conférence et c'est pas
la même chose c'est un petit peu un
petit peu plus difficile mais c'est vrai
que
il a été observé quand même un nombre
d'appel s relatifs à l'isolement relatif
à la solitude on retrouve ce qu'a dit
l'écoutant de de solitude d'écoute
style d'écoute mode d'écoute à ses
voisins de suicider
la solitude aujourd'hui
a considérablement augmenté dans notre
société du fait de la crise sanitaire
sans doute mais peut-être pas seulement
je vous laisse le mot de la fin
peut-être à propos de l'augmentation de
ces de ces écoutes oui dans la dans la
crise bien sûr sanitaire que nous
traversons alors on voit une
stabilisation donc à un niveau très haut
le plus haut niveau que l'on a eu par
rapport aux années précédentes de la
crise sanitaire et on a une certaine
inquiétude sur le fait que cette courbe
qui pour l'instant est plate ne
redescendent pas parce qu'il va nous
falloir avoir de nouveaux contingents de
bénévoles d'abord parce qu'il y a un
renouvellement générationnel mais il
faut aussi qu'on est davantage de
vocation alors on a eu un afflux de
demande mais on ne prend que 10% des des
candidatures parce que la sélection est
très difficile et elle est très sévère
rigoureuse et ça prend du temps en plus
voilà
pour que les gens nous rejoignent si
notre engager dans quelque chose de
passionnant on espère que ce qui a été
notre discussion notre échange et ce
documentaire que nous avons proposé
aujourd'hui dans des bagues va vous
donner envie à vous aussi de faire
partie de ces fameuses écoutons dont on
a parlé avec vous tous les trois sur ce
plateau aujourd'hui un grand merci
réaction ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter bien entendu et puis vous
pourrez vous même réagir à ce que sont
ces réactions merci aussi à sel massali
qui comme elle a coutumé m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain les Badoc
avec bien sûr son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]